et j'accueille aujourd'hui Gilles Boyer
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
européen membre du parti horizon le
parti d'Édouard Philippe et je précise
que vous êtes aussi un proche d'Edouard
Philippe j'accue également sur ce
plateau Cédric Le Bihan vous êtes
dessinateur de bande dessinée et vous
signez avec le scénariste Philippe
pélaïs et bien la bande dessinée
intitulée Dans l'ombre la voici une
bande dessinée adaptée du roman
politique du même nom écrit par Edouard
Philippe et par vous Gilles Boyer
c'était en 2011 alors rapidement pour
noter les spectateurs pour et bien
situer un petit peu l'histoire dans
l'ombre ça raconte les aventures et bien
du conseiller d'un homme politique qui a
remporté la primaire de son parti pour
l'élection présidentielle mais cette
primaire est bien elle est entachée
d'une rumeur de fraude électorale et un
meurtre suspect est lié à cette affaire
de fraude Cédric Le Bihan comment est né
ce projet d'adaptation du roman
d'Édouard Philippe et de Gilles Boyer et
ben j'ai été contacté par les éditions
grand angle pour je venais de sortir de
la du bouclage de mon précédent album et
ils m'ont proposé de dessiner
l'adaptation d'un roman écrit par un par
deux personnes célèbres sur le coup il
m'avait pas dit qui je me suis dit
pourquoi pas oui allons-y et puis donc
c'est là que j'ai appris que c'était
Édouard Philippe et Gilles Boyer et donc
je me suis dit ouais ok carrément quoi
c'était j'étais très très partant donc
après j'ai eu le le scénario entre les
mains ou que j'ai pu lire et c'était
voilà ça ça a fini de me convaincre de
de d'aller sur cette adaptation vous
étiez partant est-ce que vous
connaissiez le milieu politique vous
avez déjà travaillé dessus non jamais je
c'est vrai que je je connais ce qu'on
peut en voir à la télévision ça je m'y
intéresse un petit peu parce que bon ça
faut s'intéresser à la politique c'est
ce qui régit nos vies mais sinon voilà
j'étais pas plus plus ancré là dedans
que que ça et je me dessinais pas je me
destinais pas non plus à la à la bande
dessinée politique et j'ai le Boyer
quand on vous a parlé de ce projet à
vous et à Édouard Philippe comment vous
avez réagi est-ce que c'est peut-être
même vous qu'il avait initié donc on
peut pas dire que on peut pas dire qu'on
l'a c'est vrai que lorsque la
proposition est arrivée ça nous a
surpris c'est pas un développement
auquel on avait spontanément pensé
lorsqu'on écrit un livre on pense pas
forcément une adaptation en bande
dessinée mais ça nous a tout de suite
séduit vous savez qu'on travaille aussi
sur une série télé qui est l'adaptation
de ce livre et donc lorsqu'on nous a
proposé ça on a dit on a dit banco et on
a je crois on a très bien très bien
bossé avec avec l'équipe qui a fait un
travail remarquable parce que adapter un
livre de 600 pages et en faire en faire
60 planches c'est c'est un défi qu'on
n'aurait pas pu évidemment relever tout
seul et grâce à Cédric et Philippe on a
réussi à mettre en place ce beau projet
et d'ailleurs pour tout dire tout ce
qu'on a fait nous c'est écrire le livre
justement comment vous avez travaillé
est-ce qu'il y a eu un échange entre le
scénariste Philippe Perez vous et puis
les auteurs du roman ou est-ce que vous
avez vraiment une liberté d'adaptation
alors déjà on a une liberté totale de
l'adaptation et ça je les en remercie
beaucoup ça a été ils ont été voilà ça a
été ça a été super pour ça mais et donc
Philippe lui a fait d'abord tout
l'adaptation du livre donc il a il a
compulsé le livre donc il a fait il a
écrit ce scénario là donc sur sur une
soixantaine de planches effectivement et
ensuite moi j'ai fait tout storyboard
donc c'était tout le toute la bande
dessinée mais dessiner rapidement donc
pour placer les personnages pour placer
les cases et ça on a fait une séance de
travail avec avec Monsieur Gilles Boyer
monsieur Édouard Philippe pour pour leur
soumettre ce travail là et pour leur
montrer donc donc moi comment se
présenterait la bande dessinée donc là
ils l'ont partir de là ils l'ont validé
et donc là après on a pu suivre le
suivre le cours de la de la bande
dessinée quoi donc les dessins les
ancrage la couleur est ainsi de suite et
finalement ce premier regard cette
première rencontre c'est bien passé vous
avez dit tout de suite banco on y va oui
d'abord c'était un moment d'émotion pour
nous parce que lorsqu'on imagine des
personnages d'un roman tout d'un coup on
les voit on voit des visages en tout cas
comme vous les avez imaginé donc ça
c'était un moment très émouvant ce qu'on
ce qu'on voulait nous c'était que
l'esprit du livre soit préservé et c'est
tout à fait le cas un livre qui a
vocation à raconter les coulisses d'une
campagne présidentielle la vie de
l'entourage d'un candidat ce qui peut se
passer dans cet entourage lorsque les
conditions de pression augmentent
lorsque des événements surgissent pour
bouleverser une organisation bien huilée
on voulait préserver cette état d'esprit
mais on a aussi pleinement conscience
que la BD c'est pas notre métier et que
il fallait laisser toute latitude à
Philippe pour le scénario à Cédric pour
les dessins pour l'adapter à leur idée
cette BD est bien finalement elle donne
une vision des personnages de votre
roman quels sont vos choix graphiques en
lien avec cette adaptation quel choix
vous avez fait en tant que dessinateur
je vois toujours de faire des
personnages qu'on reconnaît d'une case à
l'autre des personnages assez c'est pour
ça je voulais un graphisme assez simple
avec des couleurs assez simples parce
que c'est vrai qu'on avait une histoire
qui était déjà très très dense donc je
voulais des choses qui pouvaient se
reconnaître très rapidement donc voilà
puis il y avait aussi la volonté de
n'avoir aucune ressemblance avec qui que
ce soit dans le milieu politique
évidemment donc c'est ce qui c'est ce
qu'il y a c'est ce qui a été fait même
si fatalement on se retrouve toujours
dans des il y a toujours des gens qui
vont réussir à trouver tiens ils
ressemblent un peu à un tel ou un peu à
un tel forcément vu par le par qui ça a
été écrit à la base on y a toujours
recherché un peu mais il y avait
vraiment une volonté et ça nous avait
été demandé aussi une volonté de de nous
reconnaître strictement personne puisque
déjà dans le roman c'est c'est de la
fiction uniquement on n'en connais pas
les personnages politiques réels qui ont
et bien inspiré les personnages de
l'histoire même si le fameux candidat à
la présidentielle est appelé le patron
et je crois que c'était le surnom que
donner Edouard Philippe à un certain âge
uppé quand il travaillait à ses côtés
vous avez rappelé que le livre est sorti
en 2011 et c'est vrai que à cette époque
là on travaillait tous les deux au côté
d'Alain Juppé mais on assume notre part
d'imaginaire c'est-à-dire que aucun des
personnages du livre et donc de la BD
n'est directement inspiré d'un
personnage existant mais il y a dans la
vie politique comme dans tous les
milieux il y a des archétypes d'hommes
politiques de femmes politiques de
collaborateurs c'est ce qu'on a voulu
montrer mais aucun personnage de notre
livre n'est directement compara
un personnage existant est-ce que c'est
plus facile de dire des choses sur le
monde politique en passant par la
fiction qu'en passant par un essai vous
nous percez à jour c'est-à-dire qu'à
l'époque quand on a écrit un roman on
s'est dit on va peut-être faire pouvoir
dire à nos personnages des choses qu'on
peut pas dire nous-mêmes alors il y a 10
ans Édouard Philippe n'avait pas du tout
la notoriété qu'il a aujourd'hui il
était merdu Havre mais c'est vrai que il
y a 10 ans on se disant on va pas écrire
un essai sur nos convictions sur la
politique c'est ridicule mais en
revanche on avait envie d'exprimer à
travers la fiction la manière dont les
choses peuvent se passer dans la dans la
réalité d'un monde politique qui est
souvent décrit mais parfois mais par des
gens qui l'ont pas vécu de l'intérieur
donc c'était ça qui nous intéressait et
on trouvait que le biais de la fiction
était était plus amusant et d'ailleurs
ça le reste et puis un ton très
particulier dans cette histoire avec
également des parties humoristiques
l'intérêt de la BD c'était de garder ce
ton bah oui oui évidemment déjà parce
que le livre à la base il y a beaucoup
d'humour je pense que j'y voyais de voir
Philipp aussi beaucoup d'humour donc
ouais c'était volontaire et puis si
c'était c'était bien de garder justement
ce côté humoristique pour parler d'un
sujet grave entre guillemets mais en
tout cas un sujet politique et qui est
toujours un peu sérieux quoi donc là
c'est vrai que ça dénote un peu c'était
plutôt sympathique justement ça fait ça
fait passer le l'histoire bien plus bien
plus agréablement justement ce ton de
l'histoire qui est bien d'une certaine
manière emprunt d'humour ça correspond
aussi à vos personnalités Édouard
Philippe et agile Boyer c'est important
de le conserver dans cette bande
dessinée oh disons qu'on s'est toujours
dit que on peut faire des choses
sérieuses sans se prendre au sérieux et
que dans un univers qui est parfois
difficile si on garde pas une part de
d'humour d'autodérision de regard un
petit peu détaché du recul sur les
choses on a du mal à survivre ou à vivre
longtemps dans ce dans ce monde là donc
on a essayé de retranscrire ça dans
notre livre c'est vrai que c'est aussi
un milieu où on rigole beaucoup
lorsqu'on sait garder ça dans une équipe
il y a des événements qui arrivent bon
bah c'est difficile un espace jamais
comme prévu donc faut toujours essayer
de garder un peu de un peu de sourire un
peu d'humour et bien sûr et puis oui
alors on peut rire en politique mais on
le voit pas forcément finalement devant
le public on n'a pas cette impression
donc c'est important d'avoir ce type
d'histoire pour raconter les coulisses
oui et puis d'ailleurs je enfin je pense
il faut pas s'interdire de rire en
politique mais c'est vrai que les sujets
qu'on aborde ils prennent pas toujours
ils prennent pas toujours à la rigolade
il faut bien le reconnaître donc il faut
le faire abonner si on et je dirais que
voilà garder le recul sur soi-même le
recul sur ce qu'on fait avoir conscience
que on fait des choses sérieuses mais
que voilà pas les rois du monde je pense
que c'est important de le garder en tête
à chaque instant pour dire la vérité
alors dans l'ombre c'est le portrait
d'un conseiller d'un apparatchik de
partie vous avez été conseillé j'ai le
Boyer avant d'être élu député européen
comment vous avez vu évoluer ce rôle de
conseiller politique
je bon disons que d'abord c'est un rôle
qui est très différent selon
personnalité chaque homme ou femme
politique attend de ses proches
conseillers des choses différentes et
donc c'est avant tout une affinité
personnelle une complémentarité et ce
que on fait auprès de l'un on pourrait
pas forcément le faire auprès de l'autre
et donc c'est des rencontres c'est des
rencontres moi j'ai eu la chance jeune
de travailler aux côtés d'Alain Juppé à
Bordeaux à la mairie de Bordeaux
ministère des Affaires étrangères et
puis ensuite pour diriger la campagne
des primaires en 2016 ça a été une
aventure politique bien sûr mais avant
tout humaine et donc ce rôle il évolue
parce que lorsqu'on a écrit le livre les
réseaux sociaux n'avaient pas du tout la
place qu'ils ont aujourd'hui dans la vie
politique le débat public était
différent je sais pas s'il était
meilleur ou ou moins bien mais enfin en
tout cas il était différent donc les
choses évoluent on prend de l'âge et moi
même je pourrais plus probablement
refaire ce que je faisais il y a 20 ans
donc il faudrait inviter un de mes
collègues qui a 20 ans de moi pour qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse comparer mais c'est
vrai que le évolue parce que la vie
évolue et que la vie politique évolue
alors c'est des histoires humaines des
histoires de loyauté de fidélité mais il
y a aussi beaucoup de violence dans un
parti politique Cédric Le Bihan vous qui
n'est pas et bien un spécialiste de ce
milieu qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
relations qui sont quand même assez
violentes dans le parti des relations
que racontent ce livre bah c'est pas
étonnant quand il faut voilà quand il y
en a plusieurs qui se battent pour pour
une place en particulier surtout cette
place là c'est pas étonnant ouais qu'il
y ait des coups bas qui est des coûts
des coups un peu violents et que ouais
faut avoir les épaules larges et solides
pour pour affronter tout ça quoi et
finalement c'est un bon fil narratif qui
fonctionne que les personnes les plus
dangereuses ou finalement à nos ennemis
bien ce sont peut-être nos amis dans
notre famille politique ah ça
effectivement oui c'est sûr que on peut
jamais voilà acquisier finalement on
sait pas on sait jamais et dans ce
milieu là j'ai l'impression que c'est un
peu pareil
est-ce que cette histoire ce n'est pas
et bien un manuel anti primaire
justement un antidote contre la primaire
parce que ça montre et bien tout c'est
coût tordu qu'on peut se faire dans un
parti dans une dans une primaire oh
disons qu'on a vu qu'il y avait pas de
solution parfaite la primaire c'est à la
fois la solution la seule solution pour
départager des candidats et en même
temps c'est la pire des solutions parce
que dans les débats de primaire et bien
on s'affront entre nous et ensuite ça
laisse forcément des traces on
s'affaiblit mutuellement donc il y a pas
de solution parfaite et je vais laisser
aux parties politiques le soin de
trancher cette question la primaire de
la droite et du centre en 2016 ça a été
un formidable succès faut pas l'oublier
plus de 4 millions de personnes qui sont
venues voter vous vous souvenez des
files d'attente devant les bureaux de
vote on avait créé à cette occasion un
grand événement démocratique ce qui
parlait tant qui courent n'est pas à
rejeter ensuite c'est vrai que cette
primaire elle a aussi laissé des traces
dans le sens où le candidat qui a été
désigné il a été à l'issue d'un
processus difficile douloureux comme
toute compétition en politique mais en
même temps si cette primaire n'avait pas
eu lieu probablement il aurait jamais pu
être en situation d'être candidat ou en
tout cas aucun candidat incontesté
n'aurait pu émerger donc vous voyez
c'est un processus qui qui comprend des
avantages très puissants et des
inconvénients très puissants des
avantages et des inconvénients mais je
crois que savoir qu'il doit Philippe
n'est pas très favorable à une primaire
en tout cas pour son parti horizon en
vue de 2027 il aime pas trop cette idée
il y a pas de primaire dans les statuts
d'horizon je vous confirme donc ça sera
lui le patron pour 2027 pour la
présidentielle il sera chef du parti ça
c'est sûr je sais pas s'il le restera
jusqu'en 2027 mais en tout cas il y a
pas de primaire dans les statuts
d'horizon et on verra ensuite qui est en
situation d'être candidat donc est-ce
qu'il y a vraiment un doute sur la
candidature d'Édouard Philippe en 2027
pour horizon il y a toujours un doute à
4 ans d'une échéance mais ce Édouard dit
souvent c'est que quoi qu'il arrive il
est jamais inutile de se préparer donc
il se prépare alors cette histoire dans
l'ombre à l'étape en bande dessinée elle
est également adaptée et bien en série
télévisée sur France 2 je crois que le
tournage a est-ce que vous vous
participez comment ça se passe
le tournage a commencé la semaine
dernière moi j'étais en plénière à
Strasbourg au Parlement européen moi
j'ai pas pu encore assister à une
journée de tournage mais c'est la
concrétisation de deux ans de travail et
d'écriture parce que autant la bande
dessinée est une adaptation assez fidèle
du livre on peut le dire autant la série
télé est une adaptation beaucoup plus
libre qui a nécessité de l'imagination
un travail d'écriture très fort on a
aussi découvert avec Edouard un nouveau
nouvelle facette et un nouveau défi
parce que c'est c'est redoutablement
difficile mais aujourd'hui après deux
ans de d'écriture et de travail avec
toute l'équipe autour de Pierre solaire
le réalisateur on a commencé un tournage
qui va durer à peu près trois mois et on
espère une diffusion tout en avant l'été
prochain avant l'été 2024 donc avec
Édouard Philippe vous êtes vraiment
investi dans ce projet ça demande
peut-être plus de travail nous sommes
qu'aux Sénat nous sommes qu'aux
scénaristes alors au début on a beaucoup
conseillers les scénaristes sur ce qu'on
voulait faire de la même manière qu'on
l'a fait un peu avec vous exprimer notre
esprit expliquer notre démarche
expliquez comment les choses se passent
et puis de fil en aiguille on a été je
crois de plus en plus investi dans le
projet et à la fin on a tous les deux
beaucoup écrits et donc c'était c'était
tout à fait passionnant et finalement ce
métier de scénariste d'une série ça vous
plaît oui oui beaucoup moi je c'est une
disons que c'est une facette
supplémentaire et c'est vrai que moi qui
suis aussi romancier qui écrit des
livres c'est toujours intéressant de de
se lancer dans des défis d'écriture et
donc celui-là en éteint et de taille et
c'est très intéressant de de
dans une série on a pas le droit à
l'erreur on n'a pas le droit à l'ellipse
on doit toujours décrire à quel endroit
ça se passe avec quel personnage à quoi
il ressemble comment ils sont habillés
quels sont leurs réactions dans un livre
finalement on peut faire beaucoup
d'ellips si je décris notre plateau je
peux très bien aller dans le détail ou
bien au contraire
ne pas dire comment vous êtes habillé à
quoi vous ressemblez et donc une série
d'une certaine manière je trouve que
c'est beaucoup plus exigeant je trouve
que le public des séries est en
particulier exigeant aucun lecteur de
romans ne vous enverra un mail pour vous
dire qu'il y a eu d'erreur où il
incohérence entre la page de sang et la
page 400 en revanche les téléspectateurs
d'une série et j'espère qu'il
l'apprécieront eux ils remarquent tout
et donc c'est un c'est une bonne leçon
d'exigence alors finalement Édouard
Philippe il a investit dans beaucoup de
projets il y a c'est vraiment politique
les adaptations en bande dessinée en
série il y a aussi le fameux
documentaire Édouard mon pote de droite
est-ce que c'est une nouvelle façon de
communiquer pour un homme politique
oui je sais pas chacun fait les choses à
sa manière Edouard il a toujours eu
l'amour de la lecture et de l'écriture
et je pense qu'il a vécu ces différents
exercices comme moi comme des comme des
défis des défis d'écriture qui sont
différents et donc tout ce qui tourne
autour des mots des phrases des
dialogues nous nous intéressent et nous
passionnent on a tous les deux on a
écrit des livres ensemble on a écrit des
livres séparément on a écrit des récits
on a écrit des romans et on n'a pas
l'intention de de s'arrêter et ça fait
partie de ce que nous sommes Cédric le
bilan est-ce que ce projet il vous donne
envie de travailler et bien sur d'autres
histoires politiques et justement la
prochaine c'est encore une histoire
politique toujours chez grand-angle et
mais là on part aux États-Unis avec la
période Reagan Gorbatchev et la guerre
froide d'accord donc ça y est vous avez
goûté au virus de la police
à faire à faire un solif politique et
pourquoi pas continuer qu'est-ce qui
vous plaît dans les scénarios politiques
finalement ce sont des histoires de
passion humaine qui se concentre web je
pense que ça regroupe un peu tous les
sentiments dans les petits enfin on
trouve on trouve vraiment de tout et il
y a voilà il y a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'histoires à raconter et voilà
les les rapports entre les gens les les
voilà les les conflits les les amitiés
la fidélité ainsi de suite je pense que
ouais c'est c'est un peu ce qui régit
nos vies donc donc ouais c'est plutôt
intéressant ce qu'il y a un nouveau
livre en coécriture avec Édouard
Philippe qui en préparation pour
l'instant on écrit chacun de notre côté
comme on le fait parfois au gré des
projets on a consacré beaucoup de temps
à l'écriture de la série donc ça ça nous
a beaucoup occupé un projet commun très
exaltant et puis peut-être que ensuite
on réécrira quelque chose ensemble mais
voilà la vie est longue reste quelques
minutes je vais vous poser quelques
questions politiques je profite de votre
présence notamment sur Edouard Philippe
qui reste et bien l'homme politique
préféré des Français comment vous vous
expliquez cette popularité d'abord nous
n'en parlons jamais c'est vous qui m'en
parlez je vous remercie de le noter je à
la fois il vaut mieux être en haut que
de ces classements que en bas
et en même temps
en 25 ans de politique j'ai plutôt
appris que ça n'avait une signification
très relative pour l'avenir
et donc c'est pas ce qui nous guide
Edward Philippe s'est lancé dans un
travail de structuration de son
mouvement politique horizon de réflexion
sur les idées il voit beaucoup de monde
je croyais qu'il est en train d'écrire
un livre où il essaye de mettre un
certain nombre d'idées sur le papier
donc c'est un travail de préparation qui
commence et ensuite on verra bien ce que
l'avenir nous réserve c'est vrai qu'il
reçoit lorsqu'il se déplace un bon
accueil mais c'est des instruments de
mesure dont j'ai appris à évaluer la
fragilité à son atout c'est aussi que
politiquement il peut rassembler les
électeurs de droite il y a et bien
récent sondage qui montre que justement
les Français pensent qu'il est celui qui
peut rassembler cette partie de
l'électorat
personne ne sait à 4 ans de l'échéance
quels seront les grands pôles et les
grandes lignes de fracture de l'élection
présidentielle de 2027 donc c'est
beaucoup trop tôt pour dire qui pourrait
être le candidat de Qui ce qui est
important comme je l'ai rappelé c'est de
cette se préparer c'est d'être prêt pour
une campagne qui va être qui va être
difficile évidemment et personne ne sait
les sujets sur lesquels elle va elle va
porter donc il faut être prêt à tout
affronter et ensuite on verra bien qui
est en situation
de convaincre le maximum de nos
concitoyens évidemment en tout cas quand
on regarde les sondages de popularité
des responsables politiques il y a un
petit peu en duel qui est en train de se
jouer entre Edouard Philippe et Marine
Le Pen et d'ailleurs selon les sondages
et bien Édouard Philippe seraient au
premier tour au coude à coup dans 2027
avec Marine Le Pen c'est est-ce que
c'est le duel annoncé où il faut faire
attention à cette notion de duel annoncé
j'avoue que j'étais très déconcerté par
l'apparition de sondages pour l'élection
potentiel de 2027 à 4 ans de l'échéance
et donc pour moi ça n'a aucune
signification je comprends que vous m'en
parliez je comprends aussi que tout le
monde les regarde et y compris
nous-mêmes d'ailleurs mais moi à titre
personnel je me garde bien en tirer la
moindre la moindre conclusion
qu'il faut regarder on a beaucoup
d'horizons mais évidemment que tout le
monde a ça en ligne de mire président de
la République ne sera pas en situation
de se représenter de par la Constitution
et donc par conséquent le jeu le jeu est
ouvert mais aujourd'hui savoir ce qui va
se passer moi je ne suis pas j'ai pas de
boule de cristal malheureusement et dans
cette période de tension sociale après
cette période compliquée de la réforme
des retraites finalement est-ce que et
bien l'enjeu n'est pas avec une certaine
certitude quand même de battre Marine Le
Pen qui a un boulevard politique on le
voit sa popularité augmente dans cette
période de tension bon je pense que quoi
qu'il arrive il faudra faire campagne
pour quelque chose et pas contre
quelqu'un ça me semble beaucoup plus
important la politique c'est de c'est de
convaincre c'est pas d'expliquer que que
que l'adversaire et le diable et donc il
faudra présenter un projet positif un
projet optimiste
plutôt que de céder à la tentation de
dire il faut empêcher quelqu'un d'être
élu je pense pas que ça puisse
fonctionner merci beaucoup messieurs
d'être venu sur le plateau de bonjour
chez vous je rappelle et bien cette
bande dessinée que vous signez Cédric Le
Bihan que vous dessinez et signé avec le
scénariste Philippe Pelaez la bande
dessinée dans l'ombre qui est adaptée du
roman politique du même nom écrit par
vous Gilles Boyer et par Édouard
Philippe merci beaucoup d'avoir été nos
invités ce vendredi tout de suite le
club des territoires